this is a big news the Senate
Intelligence Committee has confirmed
that Russia did in fact interfere in the
2016 presidential elections so that's
official now yeah
in response Russia said no shitski
Sherlock it's an actual quote that's no
shitski Sherlock Russian I'll kind of
known that for a while anyway oh yeah I
thought you're just gonna talk about how
what an easy language Russian is yeah
you just go she had ski to the end of
anything what kind of craps tea is this
your Russian is very good this is
interesting president Trump's first wife
Ivana she has not been speaking out much
not giving a lot of interviews well
she's finally given a long interview and
Ivana claims that Donald Trump talks to
her at least four times a month yeah
yeah which if you're counting is twice
as much as he talks to Melania wait yeah
that's quite a lot of
can't take my eyes off that shirt I know
we did I know we didn't make that shirt
is there a label on that shirt I got to
keep working here but I'll get back to
you
hey this check this out the the Spanish
region of Catalonia is expected to
declare independence on Monday on
Tuesday they'll be looking for a job and
by Wednesday they'll be back in Spain
saying hey can I crash here for a month
those Catalonians doesn't deserve
applause a manager at a McDonald's in
the Bronx was arrested for selling
cocaine along with the food yeah thority
suspected cocaine when they saw these
sign outside McDonald's that said 1
billion served just this morning
you